Speaker 1: as a Fox News debate between Geraldo
Rivera and radical right wing former Secret
Service agent Dan Bongino exploded last night
into screaming and insults. And, you know,
in this segment, I don't actually care to talk
about the substance of what Geraldo and Dan
Bongino are talking about. What I want to talk
about is how worthless this type of media is.
And it actually relates to this show in a way as
well. And something we've been doing or not doing,
maybe better said. We're going to look at
a segment on Fox News that is now down to
the level of those sort of like Internet blood
sports type channels. If you haven't seen them,
good, you're missing nothing but the way that
these Internet blood sports channels work. Are
there live streams where you might have two
people plus a host or like a panel of four?
Sometimes it's 10 people just screaming at
each other. Sometimes these things go three,
four or five hours. No one learns anything.
I'm often invited to participate in them,
and I never do because I don't want to waste my
time. Let's look at this segment. The general
topic is the unrest in Minnesota surrounding
the police shooting of 20 year old Donte Wright.
The police officer has been charged with second
degree manslaughter. We will be talking about
the charge on today's bonus show. Of course, Dan
Bongino in this segment is not being particularly
sympathetic to the victim and their family, and
it just completely explodes and devolves into
screaming and insults. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: You tell that to the black families
that see their sons being killed.
That's all you want to write something
out, but nothing else. That's a fact. You've
got nothing. You want to see the country. You
just want to see the country burn. That's it. I
want to see the country burn. You son of a bitch.
I want to feel like you're nothing but a punk.
Yeah, you're a punk band. You know you're a punk.
You wouldn't tell me that to my face.
Speaker 1: We'll leave it there.
Coming up, the left continue. Now, if your
instinct is like mine, at least initially,
you feel like, OK, it sort of seems like Heraldo
is more on the right side here than Dan Bongino.
I hear her also talking about the relative rate
of police shootings against black man versus
white men. OK, maybe like the broader maybe in
some sense Heraldo is making more sense here.
The broader analysis is that this is trash, this
is garbage. You know, those Russian nested dolls,
they're called matryoshka dolls. You open one and
there's another slightly smaller doll inside and
then you open that one and, you know, all
the all the way down. That's what this is
of nonsense. And what I mean by that is you start
with the big picture, right? The biggest doll,
Fox News, is a propaganda network with a right
wing slant. They deliberately blur the lines
between news and opinion, and they use that
blurring to feed ignorant right wingers exactly
what they want while running interference and
carrying water for Republican politicians and
administrations. That's Fox big picture. OK, you
open that up. You look at an individual show,
the individual shows are just a disaster.
You've got Gut Gutfeld, the supposed comedy
show. It's not funny. You have Jeanine Pirro
on the weekends when she's not drunk. She's
making no sense anyway. You've got, you know,
Hannity, Tucker Carlson. They have completely
bamboozled their audiences into thinking that
they report news when they get sued. Their lawyers
will quickly say this is entertainment, this is
entertainment. But the viewers don't realize that
you have Hannity, who's friends with Trump and
repeats Trump's propaganda, and people watch it
and they don't realize this is just Trump's friend
feeding me nonsense. You have Tucker Carlson,
who's doing subtle white nationalists talking
points. We talked about that earlier this week.
You open up the individual show box and then you
get to a specific episode about what's going on in
Minneapolis, where the entire framing is always to
defer and default to the position of police. You
open that up and you get to this single segment
with Geraldo and Dan Bongino. It's a debate
supposedly to give us two opinions. Maybe her
all those opinion is a better one than Bongino,
but it's all sensationalist trash. It's just
blood sports from which we learn nothing.
And this is partially why I've done less and less
of the debate, the right stuff with bad faith
people all the time. We used to bring on just
these morons, bad faith right wingers, and I would
argue with them and it was interesting, sort of
like for shock value and entertainment value, and
they did pretty well, but we didn't really learn
anything. And no one learns anything from this.
It's just garbage. It's not worth the electricity
and the bandwidth required to produce it and to
watch it. One more segment from this just to
show you how completely vapid it is statistics.
Speaker 2: But he doesn't know any of that. But
secondly, this is again, why what you know about
politics. You have a ten minute career
as a Colorado. You've got to be careful.
Speaker 3: Are you take a value.
Speaker 1:
So my hope is and I've said this before. I hope
that people watch some shows like mine, not trying
to put myself out of business, but my shows, if
you think of a food pyramid where you put the junk
food at the top. I hope that people are building
their knowledge of the world and have important
issues. First, by understanding how to think
epistemology, critical thinking, media literacy.
On top of that, you build your knowledge of
history and geopolitics and political philosophy
by reading books. On top of that, you read
reporting, ideally original reporting,
and then you pick some commentary and opinion
like my show at the top of the pyramid for flavor.
Right? If you're only watching Fox News and many
people are only watching Fox News, that's where
they get everything. They get their world view.
They get their you know, everything comes from
from Fox News. If that's how you learn and you
get informed, it's a disaster and we will never
solve the problems that we have in this country.
So, you know, I don't even care to adjudicate
Heraldo versus Dan Bongino here. This is just
like the logical end point of, as we, you know,
unpacked those Russian dolls. When you start with
what Fox News is and you go to what shows are on
Fox News, and then you look at the hosts that Fox
News selects, and then you go down to the segment
level, you get a segment that is of I would
it's not even zero value. I would argue it's of
negative value. If that's how you inform yourself
about the issue in Minneapolis, you end up less
informed and less able to really understand what's
going on. If this is what counts as news for you,
let me know what you think. Am I being too
harsh? Find me on Twitter at David Pakman